Một bộ tháng 12, các bạn nghĩ khu trăm à mi sấu, công an phường tránh hơn, tình phố chiming,
phát thông bảo truy tình thông tin an nhân phục vụ công tất đều tra.
Chứ đó, và khoảng chính dựa 3 phút ngày 18, các bạn nghĩ khu trăm à mi sấu,
các bạn có quan tức dẫn tin bảo về việc phát hiện một tự tiến lưỡi trong một bảo mổ xanh tại bởi kẹ phía sau công tiêm mê mặc xe gần bà, phường về bình, tình phố chiming,
tông tin bản đầu, nạn nhân lã nữa giới khoảng 4.5 năm, các bạn một mấy sống mới, thế trạng Trung bình.
Tóc dài mổ nô đàn, mong tay, mong trên sình mổ hợp, không có hình 3 trên cơ thị, mặc át thùn và lỗ mổ đàn,
cười lốt mổ đàn, quần sốt mổ đàn, khoảng 3 miệm mạnh đầu, nạn nhân được sất định đã từ vong khoảng triệu bộ nè trước thử định được phát hiện.
Để nghịn người dân liều có người thân, người quán có đặc điểm những giảng miêu trên mất lyd là từ khoảng 18,
bà thông bệnh năng ngày 20, xa 20 xa vẻ trước khoảng phát hiện thông tin, liên quan đến nạn nhân, lưỡi tưởng nghi vấn, phương tịt,
khi điểm hoặc cá sấu hiệu có lý quan đến vụ việc, vui lòng liên dịnh ngày cơ quan cạnh rất điều tra công hàn thành phố chiming,
phòng cạnh rất hiện sự, số địa thoại không sau chiến 3 1 8 8 12 2 khu không, khoảng cơ quan công an tình nhất để cũng có thương tin.
Mọi thông tin giòn người dân cũng có phát hiện được tiếp nhận, sắp mình và bảo mật thân quy định,
có phần vụ trở cơ quan công an nhân trong xác định dính tính nạn nhân và điều tra làm só vụ việc.